Hello there the Internet. I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slo Mo Guys.
And this video is all about odd and weird
slow-mo perspectives innit?
Yeah, I'm quite lazy so
when I make a cup of tea,
or whatever I don't really
like to stir with a spoon
so I've got one of these, stirry cups.
And I've wanted to use this
probe lens a few more times
because it gets some
really interesting angles,
somewhere you can
usually never get a lens.
And I thought it'd be cool
if we sort of dumped it
in a spinning drink,
from high up like that.
But I don't really have the sort of...
You're wobbling everywhere.
Repeatable skill.
So we've got this camera slider.
It's mounted vertically
instead of horizontally.
And it has a counterweight and a rope.
So we can actually mount
the camera on this.
And usually it's used
for sort of, nice smooth
vertical shots.
We're gonna mount it like this.
Not recommended.
It's a lot of weight.
This is a small head.
Quite a small little head.
Lovely.
Pretty good?
It's pretty much, right?
Cause there's a little
plastic thing in the bottom
of this cup, and if you hit
it it will probably break.
And it's this far away from hitting it.
So I think over time it'll
sort of bend inwards.
When it comes right to the bottom, yeah.
I always get zapped by American plugs.
Yeah me too.
Got that BNC?
Yeah I'll go get it.
That has got to one of
the most mental setups
we've ever had.
I quite like it.
The monitor being on the camera is
too heavy on the front end.
So that's separate now.
It's got a longer cable.
And our final operation is
gonna look something like this.
It's actually quite sturdy,
for the amount of weight
on it's tiny little head.
You wanna give us a
little demo of this cup?
Sure. It's not actually a coffee cup,
it's sort of a mixing thing.
But it really...
It really goes doesn't it?
Doesn't mess about does it?
I wonder if we get some
shots through the side,
it might look cool enough just
to see that vortex in slow-mo.
That's what I thought, I
thought it would be pretty cool
because it's all messy down here
and in slow-mo you're going to
see some cool stuff I think.
All right get it spinning.
I'm gonna put a little
bit more in, actually.
Yeah.
That's maximum spin height.
All right here we go.
Yeah.
Stop there.
Whoa!
Is it good?
That's really trippy.
Put your face in that.
That is mental. What is going on there?
Because it's in slow motion
it makes it look so much
bigger, it looks like you're doing
it to giant pool.
Yeah it's hard to get an idea
of what the scale of that is, isn't it?
Yeah, by the numbers down the side
could easily be in meters.
Focus is banging though,
it tracks it all the way
through down to the bottom.
What I should probably mention is
the widest possible aperture on this probe
lens is an f/14.
So it is an incredible sucker of light.
So we might need to get a
little bit of additional light.
Cause the sun, inconsiderate,
not bright enough.
What do you think?
Yeah I've got one of these,
this is wicked actually.
It looks like you're in a washing machine.
Yeah!
Should we put some food
coloring in at some point,
do you think?
Yeah.
Yeah?
For sure.
And... good.
Stop.
Oh yeah get a look on that.
So smooth!
That is wicked.
Okay let's try with some food coloring.
The light as well?
Yeah.
Okay. I'll go for green first.
It's getting heavier.
Yep.
As I come in add the coloring.
As soon you start moving?
Pretty much yeah.
Okay cool.
I'll turn it on.
Light?
And go.
Whoa!
Trippy!
That was really weird.
Oh!
Sorry.
Where?
Sorry!
I forgot to didn't have to push the button
so it gets to spitting more everywhere.
Okay let's have a little gander at this.
Oh God!
The glob came out like right next to me.
Whoa! That's amazing!
Is it good?
It's really good.
Oh man, it looks like, you
know that bit in Star Trek
where there's that red goo
that turns into black holes?
Yeah.
It looks like that, it looks like it's in
zero-g drops.
Did you see the one
that hit the side of it?
Whoa!
Yeah.
It's like skidded down the side.
It's like a secondary drop.
Love it.
That is wicked.
And there's a third drop there.
And you're clearly moving
further and further down there.
That's so cool.
It looks like The Matrix now.
Yeah.
All right I'm gonna
come down faster this time.
Okay.
So hopefully keep up with your drobules.
Three two one!
Three two one, go!
Next experiment!
Yeah we're gonna do some tea,
I'm pouring milk into tea.
See what it looks like when it's poured,
from the same weird perspective.
Yeah, I've always wondered what it would
be like to be milk.
So this angle should show us.
This is some solid tea as well, actually.
I brewed this for about 45 minutes.
Okay, turning it on.
Getting the light.
Ready?
Yeah.
Three two one, pour!
This says waterproof, I'm
not sure about milk proof.
Oh no!
You okay? Cow juice on it.
Oh! There's the milk!
An absolute glob!
Perfect!
Look at that!
Oh no, I think...
I caked the lens.
Absolutely caked it, but--
I mullered it!
There's moments where once
the milk, keep watching,
once the milk has like
subsided all the front.
It kinda looks like the
inside of someone's throat.
It looks like a gut.
It looks like a--
It looks like I'm using
one of those cameras
that goes into people's guts.
Yeah it looks like an endoscopy.
Yeah.
A colonoscopy with an endoscope.
It's quite satisfied really.
It really is actually.
The thing is, cause I poured it, it's such
a small hole to pour it into.
And the lens is taking
up most of the space.
I can't help but, cause you've got to
pour it quickly.
Yeah.
It hit the lens and it's
like wrapping around
the lens and falling down
straight in front of it.
Yeah.
This lens does actually
have a light go in.
But such a different color
temperature to the rest of the
lights we're using, but
actually I'm just not using it.
And the shadows aren't that bad.
Yeah.
Three two one go!
How's the tea?
Solid, I'd drink that.
Have a sip?
It's cold.
Oh is it?
Yeah I didn't just make it.
I guess it would steam up
the lens if it wasn't cold.
Is it better?
Yeah I'm in VR world again.
Oh nice glob, yeah?
Solid globe?
Nice glob coming in the side.
I'm a fan of that.
That's lovely.
Nothing like a nice cup
of tea for an Englishman.
It looks like the inside
of a chocolate factory.
It looks like Willy Wonka's
.
I like when the milk initially hits,
cause it's spinning, it
sprays the milk slightly
towards the center?
Yeah.
And then all the little
bits of milk that are
making it all the way to
the bottom are getting hit
by the thing.
That's very cool.
I think we've done tea proud there.
I think so.
As an Englishman, I'm
quite pleased with that.
And I don't take sugar in my tea,
I'm just sort of a milk
only sort of bloke.
You've gotta be.
But, you like a bit of sugar don't you?
Little bit of a sweet tooth?
I like it NATO.
Milk, two sugars.
NATO?
That's what it's called.
Is it?
Yeah.
Okay so the sun is sort
of behind a cloud now,
so we've brought out sun
number two for a little
additional boost.
And some dustbins.
And some dustbins because
we've blew up all our
C-stands with a Russian cannon.
All right fire!
So this rig allows for a counterweight,
to make it a lot less of a
struggle to lift back up.
But because I'm counting
so much on gravity,
we've got nothing in this,
so I just let go and it can follow that.
Yeah need the speed.
The downside is that, it's
a nightmare to hold in place
and lick back up, after
you've done it 16 times.
Okay, this is gonna be an absolute...
This is gonna be..
A bloody nightmare.
A show.
Three two one drop!
Yeah this is gonna take some doing.
Three two one drop.
Looked pretty good.
I've got tea on my lab coat.
Oh no, are you gonna be all right?
Nice core. If I was moving faster
that would have been class.
Three two one drop.
Oh. I twatted it.
That's fine.
Oh, the window of focus is so small.
Honestly it looks a
little bit like a meteor
falling into an ocean.
Pretty cool.
I just think it's not as
good when the focus is
further way, I wish it
was in focus longer.
Three two one go.
It's right in there.
Give that away.
I just couldn't stop it.
One.
No.
Two one.
It's hot in my shoe.
Everything's hot!
Everything's boiling.
The more we're doing this, the more loose
each point of failure is becoming.
So I'm slightly worried it's
going to snap off eventually.
Three two one.
Two one.
Oh! That might be it!
That might be it!
That might be it.
It wasn't spinning at all.
Was it just completely still?
It was completely, and
then it went out of focus.
Was it a good one then?
I think that's as good
as we're going to get,
for a manual system here.
And I think we just need
to take it all apart,
and if we do anymore
we'll have to just tighten
it all up and put it back together again.
Yeah we're just gonna
have to tighten it up.
The thing is, it's hard to
spin it, and also drop it,
and also time it.
Yeah. Everything is getting
pretty hot, and loose,
and the light's running
out of battery.
Feel this.
And you could fry an egg on that.
That is so hot! Isn't it hot?
I think we got some
almost very good stuff.
And if we wanna nail
that shot in the future,
we should maybe get
ahold of motion control.
A bit of mo-co, what do you think Dan?
Yeah I think so.
It'd make my job easier and your job.
Yeah let's get this phantom
off this poor tripod head.
I really like the footage we got.
Although, a deceptively
exhausting video to make.
Yeah, for you especially.
I just have to push a couple of buttons
and shine a couple of lights.
But anything with timing
is mentally frustrating.
And with all this it was like
an eventual sort of workout,
having to suspend the weight
and drop it and catch it
over and over again.
Yeah. I mean I think that
was my favorite cup of tea,
to look at,
but I can't imagine tasting
it would be very nice.
Bit cold.
All that sugar in the bottom
and it was cold as well.
That was like an inch,
Yeah!
of undissolved sugar.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video,
it was a bit of an experimental one.
But if you like those kind
of videos let us know.
And maybe we'll use this
combination of items again.
Get some even more cool stuff.
You can subscribe to us.
We've got a second channel.
And tune in for the next video.
We'll be here.
I like this thing.
Its' really cool isn't it?
Don't touch my stuff.
Sorry. That's your--
I don't touch your stuff.
That's a good point.